Welcome back everyone
It's pizza time
We started to see how Marvel is setting up
Avengers Secret Wars using the Loki series.
We know Tobey Maguire is coming back for that.
Now, we've started to see some more Easter
Eggs for that
we have a much better idea of how
they're going to use them in a big part of
that is through the Loki
and TVA characters
they already teased him coming back
with a very obvious Easter egg.
Some scenes during Spider-Man,
No way Home.
So a lot of you
are probably expecting him to come back.
This is just the beginning.
So we'll break it all down.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
My Loki Season
two Episode two video we'll post next.
Also doing a giveaway for the Loki
Blu ray.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and let me know where else
you want to see.
Tobey Maguire.
Spider-Man Come back after Secret Wars.
this season on Loki.
They're spending the first half of the
season, maybe the entire season,
because I do think we saw some moments
from the finale during episode one
with Loki jumping through the timeline.
They're trying to fix the timeline
just in general,
stop it from being destroyed,
which would basically mean
the collapse of all realities,
like let's take the multiverse again.
we're going to see a version
of that play out in Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty, then Secret Wars.
So those movies are back to back
like Infinity War and Endgame
some of the other upcoming Marvel movies
are going to directly set up
one of those movies,
or both of them, like Deadpool
three, is more connected
to what's happening
in Secret Wars than it is to Kang Dynasty.
Even though
the plots of those movies are similar.
But once the Loki characters flex,
take the timeline enough
during season two
to stop it from collapsing their next job.
And this also gets into what's happening
during Deadpool three is saving
as many people as possible
before all of reality breaks down.
And this is from across
all universes, basically implying
that at the end of Loki season two,
they don't totally fix the timeline.
Like things are not completely made whole.
They only slow down
the destruction of the multiverse,
which a lot of you probably predicted.
sounds like a very Loki thing
for them to do,
like they save some things, but also cause
bigger problems at the same time.
Just like season one, they stopped, he
who remains king But in doing
so, freed the Council of Kangs,
who are much, much worse.
So when the TVA characters like Mobius
start trying to grab as many characters
from across the multiverse
before everything is totally destroyed,
that's how they explain bringing back
Tobey Maguire.
Spider-Man after Spider-Man, No way home
in addition to a bunch of other legacy
characters in the same way.
Deadpool three
bring back a bunch of the classic X-Men
and other Fox Marvel characters
like Andrew Garfield,
Spider-Man will come back to
but this video is a little bit
more about Tobey Maguire.
Spider-Man
Secret Wars is like a much bigger version
of what's happening in Deadpool three.
Deadpool three is kind of like
Kevin Biggie's test run
to see how everybody responds
to those classic X-Men coming back in.
If it does as well as it seems like
it will, it
seems like it's going to do gangbusters,
Then Marvel will double down even harder
on that concept of bringing legacy
characters back during secret wars.
by the events of Deadpool three, though,
there'll be so many incursions
happening across the multiverse,
we started to see that
in some of the previous
Marvel movies, Deadpool Wolverine causing
more of them themselves in that movie.
In the MCU version of Deadpool Kills
the Marvel Universe, basically,
we know that Mobius is going to be
a big character during Deadpool three.
As is missed minutes, some of other
brand new TVA characters are introducing
specifically for that movie,
like other new hunters and judges.
we have the TVA essentially saving
all these multiverse characters
like Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man,
and putting them on what will be early
theory, the Void planet from season one.
And it's supposed to be kind of
like the MCU version of Battle World
in the Secret Wars plot,
and part of Marvel's larger idea
in bringing Tobey Maguire Spider-Man back
and making him a really big character
during Secret Wars
is that he's supposed to help lead
this multiverse Avengers team.
The Doctor Strange will help assemble
like Avengers assemble, but it's Tobey
Maguire, Spider-Man, Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine in a bunch of other classic
characters coming back
And this is sort
of the escalation of things after the main
616 new Avengers, like Anthony Mackie,
Captain America's New Avengers
failed to kill the Council of Kangs
and failed to save the multiverse.
That's where we get to the whole Infinity
War and endgame relationship
between Avengers 5 and Avengers 6.
like this, a very Empire Strikes Back Down
kind of ending
during Kang Dynasty, kind of like
the end of Infinity War with the snap.
The Secret Wars is like the big
rally moment,
but it involves a lot of these legacy
actors like Tobey Maguire,
Spider-Man coming back.
imagine a much, much bigger multiverse
version of this final battle
during Avengers Endgame.
I believe right now
they're planning to structure Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty,
kind of like they structured Infinity War
where there are a couple different teams
of Avengers in different locations
fighting different Kang variants,
the ones that we saw in the Army
and the WASP Quantumania Post-Credits
scene like one team will fight immortals,
another team will fight Scarlet Centurion,
another team will fight
the Rama version of Kang.
some of them will win those fights,
some of them will lose.
But ultimately those Avengers will fail
to save the multiverse.
the downer ending to that movie
is basically something like the remaining
universes collapsing,
like the last remaining incursions.
But because of the TVA
this whole time, these last several movies
since Loki Season two have been saving
multiverse characters in the background,
sending them to this battle world
location doctor.
Strange winds up
surviving the collapse of the multiverse.
Kind of like Doctor Strange Supreme in
what if
and he finds these multiverse characters
forming them into a team led
by Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man,
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine.
So in this way,
they're supposed to use secret wars
to give Tobey Maguire, Andrew Garfield.
Hugh Jackman will bring other
classic X-Men, other classic Marvel Fox
actors coming back,
their version of Avengers Endgame.
like a real big going out
swan song kind of movie before
Marvel does a soft reboot, recasting
a lot of those classic characters.
that's
why you probably heard about Wolverine
not being in that brand new solo X-Men
movie that Marvel's developing right now.
I just did a video about that,
so I'll link up along the description.
But basically Marvel is doing
their new X-Men movie with a bunch of the
recast versions of characters.
but the reason why Wolverine isn't
going to be in that first new X-Men solo
movie is because Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine will still be the main Wolverine
until after Secret Wars.
getting back to the Loki
character, the TVA.
He's going to be a big part
of King Dynasty
and Secret wars,
because so much of the plot
of the next couple of years of Marvel,
the next Avengers
movies will revolve around
what's happening at the TVA right
now, Everything during Loki, Season
two is meant to directly set that up.
Like you can see reality
collapsing in the background,
like, well, flex tape it briefly,
but we're not going to fix everything.
It's just going to continue to get worse
until we get to secret wars.
sort of be a little bit like Avengers
six piece of time.
They're couple rumors about them
having some pizza time Easter eggs
during Deadpool three.
That feels like a very Deadpool thing
to do
just because it's so over-the-top
and jokey.
let me know in the comments
if you want them to bring Tobey Maguire,
Spider-Man
or Andrew Garfield back after Secret Wars,
just because so much of
this is hinging on a big final
going out endgame moment
for a lot of these legacy actors.
Sony definitely seems like
they want to get them to come back
as much as possible for their own
Spider-Man spin off universe of movies
because they've been teasing so much
in this Venom verse, like there's
a Spider-Man in there somewhere,
but they haven't confirmed
exactly who it is.
Just because there were so many crazy
Easter eggs in Morbius
like every single Spider-Man Easter egg
from every Spider-Man
movie in every version ever,
all at the same time.
They also might wind up
using the live action.
Miles Morales For a lot of those spin off
Venom verse movies, do
they need a version of Spider-Man
to show up at some point
during those Sinister Six movies?
Tom Holland
isn't going to be in all those movies.
Like he's
not going to make 20 Spider-Man movies.
He's mostly focused on the main MCU
Spider-Man movies like Spider-Man four,
in the Avengers movies
that's why he didn't come back to do
The Voice for Spider-Man during the What
If series or Spider-Man freshman year.
That's like a totally different actor,
even though it's
meant to be a version of MCU, Spider-Man
but you can see how they're making Loki
a central figure in everything
that's happening
in this saga of Marvel movies,
the multiverse saga just in general.
They actually said that during Loki season
one, Sylvie, killing his remains
is what set everything off like
they were the beginning of all this stuff
that's happening right now
in as far as I know, they're focusing
more on Tobey Maguire, Spider-Man, Andrew
Garfield, Spider-Man in Secret Wars
than they are Tom Holland's Spider-Man.
He's supposed to be one of the main
characters during Kang Dynasty.
So one of the other big differences
between Kang Dynasty in Secret Wars
is that they're focusing on
completely different groups of characters.
Avengers 5 is mostly about
like the main universe
version of the New Avengers
versus the Council of Kang's secret Wars
is like a completely different beast
against a completely different version
of Kang who comes back
supposed to be kind of like the beyond her
in the Secret Wars equation of things.
There are a lot of theories about which
variant of Kang that's going to be like.
They might actually bring back
that one who supposedly quote unquote died
during Ant-Man, the WASP Quantumania.
Even though that was a big mistake,
he should have won that fight.
merrily theory right
now, as we'll just say
that something happened to him
when he was sucked
into his multiverse engine,
turning him into someone with near
God tier power
they haven't said anything about
recasting the actor or anything like that,
but if they want to bring in a
totally different actor
to play that beyond or variant of Kang,
they can actually explain that the process
of him evolving into a higher level
being with more power is what makes him
look different then that multiverse
version of the Avengers team
with all the different actors coming back.
We'll fight that version of Kang,
they'll win, and whether or not
they split into two different movies
remains to be seen.
If they split secret wars into two movies,
then you'll probably see more.
The main version of Avengers from the main
MCU come back and that. But.
I believe this is where we get to the soft
reboot that Marvel is kind of doing
heading forward into Marvel Phase seven,
just making it easier
for like brand new viewers to jump on
without
having to watch like 50 Marvel movies,
mostly focusing on the X-Men of it all.
Just because they'll be
like the fresh new main group
that Marvel focuses
most of their attention on, like the
mutant saga for the next three phases,
starting with Marvel Phase seven.
post all your theories
in the comments below.
There's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
My Loki Season
two Episode two video we'll post next.
Like I said,
things are just going to continue
to get crazier and crazier on that show.
I'll do an episode three trailer
video later this weekend and I think
we also might get an Invincible Season
2 trailer this weekend to that's
probably one of the best superhero series
that we've seen the last several years.
click here for that.
Loki Season 2 Episode
2 Video Update the link As soon as
I post that and click here
for my full episode one video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!